Start with decision tables. This is a common way for, getting a,
getting your head wrapped around a situation where there are various different,
states that can affect ultimate behavior of the system. If you,
if you think about decision tables in terms of input conditions and and, and,
and responses to those inputs. That is combinations of inputs yielding results.
That's where the term netwire comes from. The table will have columns.
Some of which correspond to the inputs and the remainder will correspond to
the outputs. And then each of the rows is going to correspond to a different
combination of input values. Let's imagine that we have a workshop and
there are three switches, okay. Each of the switches can have on and
off as possible values, okay? So we're going to have three columns and
eight rows. Where did the eight come from? Well, if we have three switches,
two possible values for each switch, that's two to the third or
eight. Let's assume that the three switches control two output devices.
Maybe an overhead light and maybe a, a power drill.
The third switch is a master switch which controls all the electricity in
the workshop. Well here's the, here's the decision table for this situation.
Partitioned the columns into three input columns for
the three different switches and two Output columns for
the lights and the motor on the power drill. Each of
the rows correspond to one of the possible combinations of the values for
the input switches. Due to the third,
eight different rows there. For each of the combinations of the inputs
there'll be a resulting situation as far as the outputs are concerned. So
for example, if the master control switch is off then it doesn't matter
the positions of the other switches, both the lights and the motor will be off.